[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur welt heute gibt
eine tolle mutter packt orte innovative
hier eine ganz ohne vom land und zwar
habe ich einen cache gepackten welche
deswegen weil man von außen schön ins
innere schauen kann und gleich sieht was
kommt denn auch nicht so wenn ich ihnen
diese tolle traute ein weißer genau man
gegenwärtig die heilige hand wo warst du
auch schon mal weg hochzeit mit eiscreme
des videos komme und hier habe ich jetzt
drei bilden und phasen des mandl bilden
im innern habe ich eine frische sahne
creme mit vanille hier kurz überlegen
müssen und darin habe ich ein erdbeer
rhabarber kompott und dekoriert habe ich
das ganze mit erdbeeren und mit blumen
und viel frische blumen essbare blumen
später was dazu und hier habe ich noch
aufladen clown richtig schön und vor
allem meine mama würde sich sehr über
diese torte freundin meine mama liebt
wird überall flogen im ganzen haus und
die gewinnt auch manchmal diesen
balkonblumen preis bei uns in waghäusel
doch diese sekte bekam habe ich alle
lesen und dann wünscht seinen balkon und
dann wird das getestete dann wird es
eben bewertet die laufen dann durch die
straßen und dann wird produziert und ich
warte auch schon bei der preisverleihung
mit dabei war voll cool ich hoffe meine
mama gewinn doch dieses jahr unter dem
moment schon oft auch gewonnen
ich glaube schon jedenfalls ist immer
sehr schön wenn das war cool so richtig
schön blut kann man das sagen jedenfalls
zeige ich euch jetzt wie man diese torte
herstellt dafür hatte ich zuerst einmal
die mandel bilden und zeigt hier die
zutaten für den teig brauche ich die
eier 200 gramm zucker etwas noch nie lag
trucks und eine prise salz jeweils 200
milliliter sonnenblumen
meral wache ich habe ich 300 drei
viertel vier läufe backpulver und 50 vom
wandel für den reichen nämlich jetzt
zuerst einmal die eier
sie sollten schönes zimmer waren seien
so lassen sich am besten aufschlagen und
sitzt jetzt ein ganz normaler regentag
das heißt jetzt auch zucker mit ryan
o'neal extrakt und soll
und dann verliere ich jetzt die eier
zucker muss für etwa vier bis fünf
minuten und in der zwischenzeit kann ich
schon mal die mandeln nehmen und die
fein mahlen
[Musik]
zucker maßen schön schaumig jetzt kommen
die 240 keiten bei niedriger stufe davor
jetzt kommen auch die restlichen zutaten
dafür für mich jetzt backpulver
miteinander und auch die gemeinde die
zutaten werde jetzt nur noch kurz ein
gerührt jetzt ist der teig fertig und
jetzt kann ich ihnen auch meine
bettringer teil
ich packe jetzt heute in 320 cm bringen
falls ihr nicht so viele habt dann könnt
ihr auch nur zwei nehmen und zum
beispiel später beide einfach durch teil
da habt ihr vier böden macht es einfach
so wie es bei euch am besten passt oder
ihr könnt auch die zeit einfach
nacheinander backen aber dann würde ich
sie auch einzeln zu bereiten so dass
einfach jetzt nicht ein kuchen draußen
stehen bleiben muss und eben somit die
luft verliert wenn es ein teil macht
jetzt einfach mit so einer schöpfkelle
da kann ich den flug storniert
[Musik]
socom detailliert in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 170 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 20 bis 25 minuten hat auf jeden
fall mit dem zahnstocher die stäbchen
probe machen und dann die blöden
abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
die torten gebacken und ich hab so
abkühlen lassen
die ständig aber noch kurz bereitet und
jetzt geht's an die füllung ich mache es
eine leckere creme mit einer
marmorierten optik und dem amok mache
ich mit erster und rhabarber zeigt euch
mal die flut haben
für die füllung brauche ich jeweils 150
gramm rhabarber und ärzte 100 gramm
zucker 100 milliliter wasser ein pixel
marke adler und hier habe ich noch 130
gramm erdbeeren
die werde ich gleich würfel mit zuerst
einmal die ersten staaten hier
daraus wird so eine art kompott gekocht
und deswegen nehme ich jetzt die
erdbeeren und den rhabarber laborwerte
stehen und die erdbeeren werden von den
grünen befreit und zwar macht jetzt hier
einfach so schön abziehen und beides
fein gewürfelt
[Musik]
ab wann kommt jetzt auch mit dem
rhabarber und das ist für mich so eine
richtig typische sommer kombination etwa
und rhabarber müssen immer zusammenhang
gebe ich da noch zucker mit rein und da
einfach zucker nach geschmack wenn die
erdbeeren süß genug sind dann könnt ihr
nun sitzen zu übernehmen ansonsten
nehmen wir noch ein bisschen mehr und
das ganze gelassener pro 15 minuten
stehen so dass einfach die flüssigkeit
ein bisschen raus kommt jetzt sieht man
hier ganz deutlich dass die flüssigkeit
ausgetreten ist und jetzt gebe ich noch
zusätzlich was mit dazu etwas ak 20
aussteller ihre mittel des praktisch der
gegenpart platine nehmen immer gerne die
pflanzliche variante das früher ich kurz
ein und dann muss ich das ganze
aufkochen lassen und zwei minuten
sprudelnd kochen lassen damit einfacher
seine wirkung entfalten kann und die
creme eben später auch investiert
[Musik]
ganze völlig jetzt um und zwar in einer
metallschüssel und dadurch jetzt runter
damit einfach ein bisschen schneller
abkühlt sonst dauert es lange und da
muss ich jetzt aber aufpassen dass es
nicht zu sehr abkühlt und einfach ein
fester club wird das heißt ich muss
jetzt aufpassen das ganze soll warm
werden und dann kann ich gleich die
würfel bemerkbar noch dazu geben dass du
dich jetzt kurz zur seite und zeigt euch
wie vor normal die zutaten für die
klinge für die creme braucht 400 gramm
sahne 500 gramm fisch gesehen programm
stufe 60 zum puderzucker etwas sonne weg
gebracht und ein päckchen sonderfahrt
und ich habe ich noch ein bisschen
besser jetzt nämlich zuerst einmal die
bahn und die werde ich jetzt erst einmal
mit dem handrührgerät investieren müssen
und dann kommen da geh' teelöffel seiner
partei
[Musik]
die steif geschlagene sahne stelle ich
jetzt club zur seite die brauche ich
sofort wieder gibt es nämlich eine
größere schüssel und gebt den frischkäse
rhein statt frischkäse könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch klar bin ich auch super
lecker für mich jetzt für den frischkäse
entschieden weil das ganze so ein
bisschen frischer schwere leicht
gefallen wird und patrick perfekten
fürchten dann gehe ich da gut dass
cooper mit rein und natürlich von den
extrakt meine lieblings tut hat da kommt
jetzt an apart mit dazu und
normalerweise nehme ich immer ein
teelöffel pro 100 gramm
die kriegen hier darf allerdings ein
bisschen fester werden denn das wird in
der gestik das heißt da kommt jetzt ein
tortenring aus drum die creme musik
sofort sobald ich sie auf die tote
streiche schon gut west seien daher dem
hierzu ein bisschen sonderbar könnte
entweder das ganze pack zu nehmen oder
einfach ein paar zweifel mehr
das ganze gut verrühren
[Musik]
da habe ich jetzt diese unter das mache
ich jetzt einfach zwei niedriger stufe
mit dem handstück gerät
[Musik]
wenn ich drei pcs dafür von dieser
rhabarber erdbeer creme und da kommt
jetzt ein bisschen von der quark sahne
rein und zwar macht man das forum
damit werden hier einrühren
aber ich gebe jetzt nicht direkt diese
magazine mischung hier mit rein sonst
lockt das ganze und ihr kennt
wahrscheinlich diese kleinen
theaterstück hinwegsehen
und so kann man doch ganz nach hinten
indem man vorher ein bisschen mit filmen
verrührt jetzt kann die torte
zusammengesetzt werden
wichtig ist dass wir immer überprüft
dass die akad ihnen natürlich auch
festwirt das heißt ich mache die
englische gruppe 1 2 esslöffel offenen
keller und dann sieht man auch gleich
optimal versetzt wird
so jetzt nehme ich den ersten
trockenboden
den frank hirt mit flüssigem erdgas
da könnt ihr zum beispiel auch ein
bisschen länger mit einem höheren
kienberger oder was auch immer ihr gerne
mit ich hab das jetzt erwärmt sich
einfach ein bisschen besser verstreichen
[Musik]
gebe ich ein drittel der krems und
verstreicht sieht ganz vorsichtig und da
kommt jetzt dieser stelle noch mit
brauche das einfach so eine leicht
variierte optik entsteht
[Musik]
er verteile ich jetzt die hälfte der app
darüber und legt den zweiten boden auf
und gefüllte torte auf diese weise die
erdbeeren kommen allerdings nur in die
mitte der torte und nicht obendrauf
[Musik]
das budget hatte jetzt weit ich
dekoriere ständig zuerst einmal für
mindestens eine stunde in den
kühlschrank
die torte kreiert ist fertig und zwar
nehme ich da jetzt noch ein paar
erdbeeren
hier habe ich noch opladen flogen und
rosen aus als papier- und ich nehme auch
essbare echte blumen bekommt ihr
interesse der oft gemüseabteilung der
biss beim globus gewollt oder ihr
bekommt er auch zum beispiel in seinen
laden das müssen auf jeden fall
umgespritzt geflogen sein
aber ich muss dazu sagen essbare blumen
sind wirklich sehr teuer deswegen würde
ich eher auf rosen auf etwas her und
aufladen blumen zurückgreifen
[Musik]
sport ist fertig jetzt kann sie
angeschnitten werden und dem rad wartet
schon oder steht schon in den
startlöchern blum ist weil sie so schaue
und blumen ja ihr fragt sich jetzt
wahrscheinlich wie schneidet man so eine
torte an es hat so eine torte sieht eben
eigentlich mal im gesamt und so stand
roth aus und dann muss man eben gucken
wie man schneidet ein glaube nicht dass
die zuschauer sich fragen wie die torte
anschneiden diverse fragen wie schmecken
die blumen ich würde die blumen die es
war so näher als vorhin eine probiert
und ich muss sagen die haben halt so
einen kleinen nach geschmack von soja
ich möchte jetzt nicht noch mal blumen
essen
aber ich finde zu einem so besonderen
anlass kann man auch gerne mal schauen
vielleicht sehr hinlege teller dran
macht es nicht so das war eine
riesensache und erzählte fischer ein
kunstwerk und auch hier in der torte
wunderschön also jetzt mal hoch
einzelprobleme einzelne zu süß extrem
fruchtig gezeigt
eigentlich ist meine motivation aber die
strecke war schrecklich schön saftig
das ist echt schwer die flora spectaris
nachgeschmack
ich habe noch viele übrigen nichts
komisches versuchen die blutwäsche aus
nicht sieht hübsch aus und die mama
freut sich ich hab eigentlich reichen
die opladener schmidt wie franzi die
oblaten ziemlich cool
slacker die rose vor allem weil ihr eure
mama oder papa oder auch jemand anderen
wie dieser torte überraschen möchte dann
schaut euch das rezept noch mal auf
meinem blog an aus dallas - lockte ihn
ich bin die torte wunderschön ich werde
definitiv auch noch mal machen denn mir
hat die creme auch besonders gut
geschmeckt und vor allem weil ich erst
bei und rhabarber dieser kombi einfach
super liegen blumen nicht schlecht ja
man gewöhnt sich das schwimmbad zu teuer
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen ich finde
das toll war vergab auch wieder
zurückgeht ist bereits gut vielleicht
auch mal mit zucker machen jedenfalls
wünscht ihr euch ganz viel spaß und
nachmachen und sie sehen uns dann
automatisch dann diplom habe ich selbst
gekaufte murad hofmann blumen
ich fand wir auch jetzt schon ein die
nicht diesen bestimmt getrennt
jedenfalls kaufe ich mir ab und zu
blumen benutze dann beim dreh und dann
habe ich ein grund dafür mittel zu
kaufen
[Musik]
übrigens muss sagen also meine mama hat
eigentlich nie gewonnen bei den blumen
wettbewerb weil mein papa immer nur
diese 20 cent blumen gekauft hat war vom
discounter und die anderen nachbarn wir
haben immer die wirkung vom gärtner cup
und die wachsen halt viel schneller und
viel besser als machst du da mit dem
mikrofon ja jedenfalls wachsen die
anderen halt viel besser als das mache
ich auch